the original thing was that I was
supposed to play that part
and uh Scorsese called me one day and he
said that they were thinking of having
the actors younger at certain areas of
the film in the beginning and he said he
thought I would be too old to make that
you know he said I might have to play
the Paul cervino role and I said but I
don't want to play that part and he said
well there's nothing you can do about it
that's that's it I might have to do this
I said but I don't want to play that
part and he cursed at me and hung up I
called him back and cursed at him and
then I waited and then I was sorry
then I called him back and I said come
on Marty can we work this out we can
make me young you know I went to Mike
Westmore and he gave me lifts and I put
a wig on and I was just playing the
character the way I was going to play
him and I was yelling at my dog kicking
my dog in the pool and showing him the
house
he was playing the part he was playing
along the dog was part of it back off